the brewer is very confident handing the
ball to brandon woodruff tonight this is
what you expect your two-time all-stars
to do is to take the mound and deliver a
quality start something brandon woodruff
has done 19 times pitch number nine in
this first played appearance of the ball
game tommy edmond
and he missed in a nine pitch at bat and
a walk terrific at bat by tommy edmond
edmond by the way has stolen six
straight bases without being caught he
has 25 on the year
runner goes that's edmond and a stolen
base for tommy edmond number 26.
putting the pressure on early it was a
great walk drawn by edmond then
utilizing that speed that we were just
talking about get yourself in a good
position here and the one-two pitch to
paul goldschmidt and goldie hits it up
the middle taken there by colton wong
and that will advance tommy edmond to
third runner on third less than two outs
how do you get him in cardinals now get
a fly ball could get a run from tyler
o'neill
o'neal sends it out to center
taylor with the catch
edmond with a tag
cardinals with a lead here in the first
inning just mention how this team has
been scoring runs early figuring out
ways to get themselves on the board get
a little momentum early on one nothing
cardinals in the first jake woodford
already has been given a one-nothing
lead love to see that you love to see it
for anybody whether it be a veteran
pitcher but certainly a younger guy you
give him a little bit of a cushion and
let him go to work here is willie adamus
as he issues a walk
so it is adamus with a good eye he draws
the one out walk first base runner for
milwaukee that'll bring up eduardo
escobar he's not running and it's lifted
down the left field line o'neal over
makes the catch
tyler o'neill on the run
again this defense coming through and
what a play by o'neal deep into the left
field corner and here is the cleanup
hitter abby sale garcia a swing and a
miss a breaking ball up and a waist
right out garcia dylan carlson st louis
right fielder to lead things off against
brandon woodruff 3-2 and a swing at a
miss went right back to the spot one
more tick on that fastball and woodruff
collects his first strikeout of the
night here's yada yada molina
swinging to miss 98 mile an hour
fastball at the neck and molina who was
getting that bat started early has no
chance to check his swing there but what
drift that is a milestone strikeout i
told you we love round numbers in
baseball that's his 200th strikeout omar
narvaez will lean things off
there's a strikeout and jake woodford
two in a row is second tonight i like
seeing that breaking ball for a strike
right there from jake woodford again
it's going to be a key to his success
two balls two strikes next to urias is a
fastball up blew him away three
strikeouts in a row for woodford a one
of them
that's a called strike three
dropped a little change up in there on
bader and strikeout number three for
brandon woodruff one away now the
pitcher woodford 2-1 pitch to woodford
is looped into right field that's a base
hit first hit of the game
and it's jake woodford getting a hit to
right off of brandon woodruff
back-to-back hits and the cardinals have
something going and now it brings in
paul goldschmidt
swing adam is powered him up
brandon woodruff one of his better
fastballs 98 miles an hour and a
strikeout of goldsmith let's strike out
number four and that's out number two
here in the third job not done yet he's
got tyler o'neill on his side sacrifice
fly for o'neill back in the first
shot adamus nice play throw the second
for the out
boy just leaned back gave himself a
little extra room on a bounce
and adamus good to have that guy back
tyrone taylor coming up for the brewers
and a strikeout for jake woodford so
jake has struck out four of the last
five that he's faced
woodruff lines one in the left field
he can really swing the bat he's got
five hits now this year two going for
adamus now
and adamus hits a fly ball into shallow
right dylan carlson is there
jake woodford through three abby garcia
coming up struck out to end the first
unit
and garcia on the first pitch fly ball
into right dylan carlson over near the
line makes the catch
dylan carlson holds on up against the
sidewall
level of difficulty high this thing is
slicing towards the stance he's got to
avert his gaze for a second to look up
see exactly how much room he has but
then fearlessly goes into the wall only
one hit tonight through the first four
innings up the middle base hit urias
with a single to start the fifth inning
that's what they needed second hit of
the ball game for milwaukee and here is
jace peterson and he got him it's a
strikeout and went with the breaking
ball five tonight for woodford second
out in the inning and here comes brandon
woodruff
lined into center but there is bader we
have played five
woodruff back on the bound to start the
six trying to keep the cardinals down
he's gonna have the top of their order
coming up
and that's in there he got it good shake
right on the edge
edmond caught guessing strikeout number
eight for brandon woodruff there's paul
goldsmith now one two and down he goes
98 miles an hour powered him up with a
fastball goldsmith strikes out for the
second time woodruff is getting stronger
that is his ninth strikeout ten in a row
six strikeouts in the ten consecutive
outs now it's tyler o'neil oh and two
here he comes and it's a cold strike
three
a changeup that's been the story of the
night woodruff with 10 k's
count of one ball and one strike on
tommy edmond
edmond hits it the other way that's a
base hit here comes neutral
he'll stop wide turn around first back
in safely two-nothing celois how about
that newt barr comes into the game he
draws a walk he steals a bag and then
tommy edmond does his thing here a man
on
with a walk third walk for the brewers
colton wong coming up now and wong sends
one of the air deep right center field
this is way back and it is off the base
of the wall
logo back to third wong in the second oh
just missed it
well he thought he got it right off the
top of the wall for colton long and a
fastball and instead it's runners at
second and third jbj junior
is going to be the pinch runner and a
guy that they've been counting on all
season long is coming to the plate in
willie adamus in the air left field back
is o'neill
he's got a strong arm both runners tag
bradley
will score as the throw comes to third
and the brewers are finally on the board
that's a nice at bat by willie adams
down one and two able to hit it deep
enough to
score the run escobar is going to be the
batter with good speed aboard at second
and colton wong
he got him a strikeout for garcia
long left stranded at second as the
tying run in this game
giovanni gallegos coming off one day of
rest had back-to-back saves think about
somebody who's been very very solid
tommy tonight a couple of strikeouts and
a fly ball to right
and garcia base hit into right field
and the brewers are alive in the ninth
tying run as a board and away on him
around the outside corner and he went
right along with it a line drive to
right all right lorenzo kane is in there
okay little half swing it's back to the
mount he goes to second out there throw
to first came safe no he's out
i beg your pardon he looks safe las diaz
wrung him up looked like he beat it but
the call at first is out les diaz a
quick release by gallegos
i mean i mean that that's ridiculous
i mean las diaz is even looking at the
play he's looking at how do you call him
out that's a big league umpire doing
that all right that's not going to take
long to overturn it's a wasted time it
shouldn't even been a
challenge winning run is aboard
first and second with one out and here
comes manny pina
pina gets under one fly ball to center
vader
kane's gonna tag bader makes the catch
throw comes to second base
and the tiger are now 90 feet away but
there are two outs
they're going to intentionally walk
yelling so that's going to load the
bases wow and put the
winning run at second base
and it's going to be pablo reyes
it is a gutsy move to put the winning
run in scoring position and it's a roll
of the dice the 2-2
he got him
a strikeout for gallegos
they strand the bases loaded and for the
first time
since the 2001 season the cardinals have
won 10 in a row